foreign
Huntsville hi James welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help
hey so I'm 23
um and I have actually purchased a house
the beginning of this year
um my issue now is I am at risk of a
foreclosure on my house
um just kind of needed some guidance I'm
kind of new to your plan and seeing
um what maybe I can do to help myself
out how many payments behind are you I
am four payments behind okay what kind
of loan FHA V A or conventional
that is a FHA okay
um why are you behind
um so I work in healthcare and I've
actually uh had coveted three times
within the last
um in the last six months as well as
some family things that kind of got me
behind on on work I work 24-hour shifts
so if I miss one shift I miss
um almost half of my check
okay uh coveted three times is 12 or 14
days 15 days
correct that does not put you four house
payments behind
there's another problem at work here
now the family stuff is much bigger than
the covet stuff
okay is that right
that there were several days that I
missed due to due to lost family members
and and things such as that yes yeah all
right tell you what we're going into a
commercial break I don't want to give
you a short answer on your home being
foreclosed answer it's too important
okay how much your house payment
uh my house payment is one thousand
fifty two dollars a month okay how many
bedrooms
uh it is a three bedroom two bath how
many roommates
I have no roommates okay um I did have
one
um so getting into that um if I'm if
that's okay
um I had some issues with the house that
were not found in the inspection and
um they were the roommates were not
comfortable with with those issues until
I got those fixed what is that
um so the insulation in the Attic causes
several air leaks um around so the the
heating and cooling is an issue
um there were some electrical issues
with power surging
um as well as uh
uh the house was built in 1985.
okay
um all right cool do you have any idea
what the house is worth today if you
talked to a real estate agent the house
is worth around one uh 195
uh that was I did try to sell the house
early early in the year because I
realized that I got into a situation
um and that's what it was appraised at
through their through their appraisers
okay and what do you owe on it
oh 180. okay cool all right good
um so what I would do number one is I'd
contact a real estate agent at
ramseysolutions.com under ELP our Ramsey
trusted real estate agent talked to a
couple of different ones uh tell them to
get over there and get it listed uh this
week so that it's on the on the market
as soon as the first of the year hits
okay we want to get that get that part
moving
um and what do you make yeah
yeah I make uh 48 five a year what do
you do
uh I work in uh the Emergency Medical
Services
you're an EMT
that's correct
James how long have you had this house
since the beginning of the year okay
okay yeah
yeah all right uh so you're working what
kind of shifts it is an EMT
um so right now our set shifts are 24 on
72 off
um trying to get in ahead of this and
get it fixed I'm working 24 on 24 off
and then 24 back on
okay so you're able to pick up extra
hours in other words yes and that raises
your 48 considerable
correct okay all right so 24 on 24 off
correct okay
all right but the 24 on as you're at the
firehouse and you may or may not be
awake you may or may not I mean you have
to be ready to make a call if the call
comes in but you can sleep correct
that's correct yeah they're not up 24
hours just for those of you listening
all right
um so you're working like a fireman type
uh with the firemen a type of a shift
okay uh
is there any scenario where he can yeah
when you're off work you can work so
when you're off work go ahead and pick
up some side stuff immediately hustle
and grind
um and you you've you've got the right
antidote which the antidote is work and
create as much money as you can create
um as fast as you can create it and
start throwing it at this here's the
thing
uh there's a couple things that give you
some peace number one with an FHA loan
there is zero chance they are going to
foreclose before you are six to seven
payments behind
so if you don't do squat which you're
not going to do but if you do nothing
you got too much
that that's great okay number one number
two if they do foreclose HUD Department
of Housing Urban Development does not
chase a deficit
on this so if they take the house back
and lose money they do not come after
you your credit will be messed up but
you don't have a deficit they're not
going to come after you
okay so these are like our worst case
scenarios that are not going to happen
understood what's going to happen is
you're going to go make a bunch of money
and you're going to get current
yes definitely
um so another question I have with this
is
um if is a quick sale something that I I
should look into a short sale a short
sale you don't need a short sale because
you've got a little bit of equity
someone will pick this up for what's
owed on it in this current market
okay because you got a cheap house and
cheap houses are hard to come by
understood there's not a lot of 185 000
houses in Huntsville Alabama it's just
that's a good that's a that's a sweet
price point it should sell it should
sell with a good realtor you may have to
you may have to do some extra cleanup
you may have to do some odds and ends
things but you need to get this thing on
the market and get it gone it is not a
blessing to you
right right and that's what I realized
whenever I after I got into the house
and started looking at everything and
and started figuring out what needed to
be done with the house
okay the the last thing is this there's
a process called a forbearance
and get with a Ramsay coach on our
website and they can help you work a
forbearance a forbearance is where they
negotiate with the mortgage company
giving them good reason to believe that
you can get caught up and the good
reason is your new budget based on all
the work you are doing and the work
you're getting ready to do that you're
not even doing yet all the income you're
creating because you're going to go
create seventy eighty thousand dollars
worth of income working uh 70 80 hours a
week right now your 23 you can do that
now what a forbearance is you're going
to pay like a payment and a half
for eight months
okay and that'll bring you current and
that also stops a foreclosure as long as
you get in the forbearance and you stick
to it so you can get with Ramsay coach
set up a forbearance of a payment and a
half and nothing precludes you from
prepaying that and stopping the
forbearance early because you made
enough money just to quote get current
understood but a payment and a half on
four payments behind I'll get you there
in eight months you see how I'm doing
that correct so you're not going to get
foreclosed on we're going to put the
house up for sale we're going to put it
on a forbearance and you're going to
work like a freaking maniac and create
money like you've never created before
in your life no excuses nothing else to
do you don't get to spend money on
anything but food lights water and house
payments that's it you don't get to do
nothing gas to get to work that's all
you just bear freaking bones so hold on
James I've been where you are I've been
scared like you are I know how it feels
we're going to help you I'll have Austin
pick up and we'll hook you up with one
of our Ramsey coaches and help you with
that forbearance part you are going to
get in touch with an ELP on the website
and you are going to pick up yet another
side job in addition to your overtime
that's good that's a tough situation but
those things that you explain those
those are good things to know about the
the 67 payments behind before they'll
come after you again it's making sure
that you understand all the facts it's
not just a bunch of unknowns floating
around in your head creating chaos you
know I feel like you gave him some real
it's probably fair to let folks I mean I
used to buy foreclosures for a living
and I've done this foreclosure
forbearances with people for 30 years
now and after that so here's the thing
HUD the FHA is the Government Federal
Government Federal housing
Administration guarantees this loan for
we'll say Countrywide okay so they have
regulations on Countrywide to keep
Countrywide from just instantly
foreclosing because if they instantly
when they foreclose FHA gets the house
back in Countrywide gets all their money
so they don't want Country-Wide just
pulling the rug on everybody I see so
they've got in order for Country-Wide
for their guarantee to get all their
money the federal guarantee the FHA
guarantee to get all their money they
have to abide by Hud's regulations on a
foreclosure scenario and have to take
certain steps there's like I don't know
there used to be 25 steps 26 steps or
whatever and it takes six months for
them to do that I see so they the
mortgage company would lose their FHA
guarantee against loss on the loan if
they don't follow those steps and those
steps take six months yeah so it's not
unusual to find an FHA that's 12 months
behind wow before it's foreclosed on but
you never see one under six months ever
a long long time I've never seen one the
more you know that's where that came
from so that that is not to abuse the
system but that's to give you peace
while you make the turnaround right